[Music]
in free additional marketing news so the
black people did for popeyes chicken
sandwich oh I finally tried it the other
day what'd you think it was oh he was
okay it was good but it wasn't like I
wouldn't get killed over did you have
the spicy chicken yeah I got the spicy
one yeah it was good it was a really
good sandwich is it 2 or 2 hours waiting
in line you waited 2 hours in line no no
I didn't but I heard there was still a
long I got one of the last four
sandwiches there that was just people be
more excited than like it was it was
amazing no it's but nothing is 2 hours
it's a good sandwich is it 2 hours good
is it worth getting stabbed or now
definitely look sandwich is worth
getting stabbed over I don't know
there's a really good one at Culver's
somebody's like one more bite Steve and
I'm stabbing you're like and you're like
go for it [ __ ] for the club at
Culver's I'll take you there
submitted by music always sleeps my
friends that's is what do you call it
slogan for his music channel music
people really don't like peloton's new
holiday ad I saw this [ __ ] I already
like this yeah yeah oh you dress the
people know the an has my full
endorsement bringing in burger you
haven't seen it that's all that is
expensive bike right yeah this is a two
thousand two hundred and forty five
dollar bike exercise like a stationary
bike thousand two thousand dollars are
these the ones when people talk to you
on it and it's got the screen so it
makes you well you can take the cycling
class journey with it yeah I don't know
forty dollars a month for a subscription
for you to get these classes in the
commercials the chicks always hop off of
it and like towel off like you just hop
off a dick like is the most satisfying
experience of her life
like I had never even heard of pellet
until this thing has its rich people
fitness yeah it's in the nice mob the
real nice bar by my house they have a
store so here we go something gives a
gift of what's happening is she looks
exactly the same after one after one
year that's probably why like their
stocks went down who's definitely like
out of shape in that first you know it's
crazy
their stock went down like a billion
[ __ ] dollars these people man today
he's calling his wife at is that what
they're saying so that's part of it so
it's kind of like what what the [ __ ]
already fit wife needs to be surprised
with an exercise bike that's [ __ ]
weird she wanted it water for cardio
sucks she looks good but a cardio some
lung capacity is not there maybe she
looks good but her she had cankles
[Laughter]
it makes your calves big yeah maybe she
had flabby inner thighs I don't know
yeah I think the biggest concern is that
she didn't even look like she changed
that she didn't change at all
this editing by the would literally
saying like this a year ago I didn't
realize how much this would change me
when she literally did not change at all
I couldn't even see a difference you
know like all the like food commercials
Riley no one better lay a finger on my
Butterfinger they don't go and then
gained 40 pounds
I'm saying look how much weight I lost
you know RI again but don't active
people wouldn't an active person want a
peloton yeah sing yeah that's okay so
these are the things that people are
pointing out so another one is the fact
that she she logged a whole year of her
exercising and saying how terrified she
was to first get on in the fridge you
like those cookies don't you like the
only thing that changed was the
positioning of the bike and that
beautiful window to the baseball year's
[Laughter]
picture of her face scared and I'm on
Twitter I didn't I had no concept why is
she giving birth I'm terrified please
help me I think the most unrealistic
thing about all of this is that they
didn't fight immediately when he gifted
her [ __ ] bike if the peloton they
just got to fix it there's gonna fix the
look of it because if it look like a
gigantic dick just look guys I think
it's just a lot like I think it's just a
branding thing I think we just shaped
the whole thing like a dildo a big
mechanical dick now that we bisect I see
how funny and weird is right like it's
weird for me to find people that get
outraged from it cuz I remember I came
out on the commercial you guys know I
watch commercials yeah you're an
aficionado apparently I wanna see the
first three seconds and I go I could
already tell I'm not there market yeah I
just tuned away and I don't get
emotionally like riled up more reactive
to what's going on
if you do if you are the market you do
get emotionally riled up if it's
inaccurate of you like let's say there
was a powerlifting commercial and
there's clear fallacies in there I'm
like [ __ ] yeah marches work yeah so
this is for fat women part sometimes the
things you say terrifies because you try
to engage with like this except for you
on the it was open with the new geo
fights take it in the dryer and she's
like 1/2 why is he in the [ __ ] dryer
and you're like like a Little Caesars
commercial was engaging with
you're like this [ __ ] [ __ ] Little
Caesars tried to tell me that six
dollars for a pizza
[Laughter]
nobody does my grandma does but that's
cuz no one talks to her you know why I
should call her I'll market call her and
then you'll be like oh this is why I
don't call you it's a big commercial
spill this lady this might be her first
big commercial and she's like happy
about it she sees the first cut and
mouth on TV she's getting obliterated by
the internet it's a national commercial
so she gets that sick check so bad she's
not the creator she's just like all made
a peloton and the director was like now
look worried and she was like okay I
guess I'll channel that when you're in a
commercial do you go sometimes some
companies do residuals sometimes you do
a buyout and you just get a flat rate
because what if she did the residuals
same but then is being passed around on
the internet so she's marrying people
yeah I don't I don't imagine so you
gonna be figures for all the wrong
reasons
like Oh kinda Johansson being the best
Asian actor in a tree the best tree yes
she's the best street she said she could
be a tree like her her argument was that
like oh I should be able to play whoever
I want if I want to play a tree I should
be able to play a treat movie for Scott
transit where she plays a treat and call
her on our Bluff yeah
take the wrong no audition will make her
a [ __ ] tree not a title party she
likes those roles true cleavage yeah she
she goes for those she was a voice in a
whole movie right yeah her you'd even
see her that was her she was a very sexy
voice as well just good AI j5u a bit
scary non-stationary actually yeah
recently I was we really want because I
had never taken a spin class before and
it's been the biggest regret of my
recent life to take it to take it or to
not have or not taking a hit before
no no to take the spin class was your
biggest we were hanging in your legs
were jelly [ __ ] oh my god I thought
that I got like I thought I ripped my
muscle like I tore my muscles in my
thighs spin classes talk goes [ __ ] up
and then I don't anyway I don't even get
to do the entire class cuz like halfway
through it like you know how they make
you like get up and then do all this
[ __ ] and get up I was just sitting there
I'm just like pedaling away I'm like I
can't even pedal at the coz they want
you to hit the certain like like if you
want to be drenched and then have a pool
of sweat underneath your bike take a
spin class and one hour it's nuts
torture than good for you but I will
never do it again I was carrying tip me
and me and everybody in our group was
carrying tip all around this whole
haunted house how long did you to
recover from that it was like a whole
week not being able to walk up and and I
live in a two-story home no three
stories and I could not [ __ ] even be
in my home I had to do it for two weeks
still used to I don't want support I
don't want it three stories is six lives
do they have telethon is there I don't
even know it in look at the bike no
three what that not because it's the
garage steps actually for
two floors it's up to four now in three
minutes if you add the little one yeah
like a town it's a town house yeah it's
like the garage to get to the living
room and then some steps to get to the
dining room and then some steps to get
through the to the other and it's five
if you count the step stool under on
some on some cloudy days on some kind of
this tip looks out from her window and
she sees the bottle of clouds
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you